as aoc goes on vacation sotomayor
spreads disinformation
yeah just days after living it up mask
us at a bar in south beach new york
congresswoman alexandria ocasio-cortez
tested positive for the coronavirus well
who could have predicted that
her office says she's experiencing
symptoms and recovering at home they
also reported she's suffering from
confusion in incoherent speech but that
has nothing to do with covid
now if you'll remember she blamed the
criticism she faced on republicans
deranged sexual frustration and being
mad that they can't date her yeah that's
why so maybe covet infected her out of
jealousy who knows now you have to stay
six feet away perverts but doctors
recommend staying so far away you can't
hear her either
so from our clueless cupid to a justice
who's just plain stupid last friday
during a hearing on biden's vaccine
mandate supreme court justice sonia
sotomayor said quote
we have over a hundred thousand children
which we've never had before in serious
condition and many on ventilators
well well that's not true it's not even
close and we have no idea where she got
that crazy number
what's scary that lady is the supreme
court justice yet it appears she has the
bs detector of a cat lady who thinks
astrology is a science
but not to be outdone justice briar
breyer claimed masks and vaccines would
prevent all cases of coven this is when
the masked and vaccinated are seeing
more breakthrough cases than the
southern border but it just goes to show
you that just because someone wears a
robe
it doesn't make him smart well unless
it's a shorty robe on a saturday night
and hammer's heating up the hot tub
yeah
sorry corey i lost my train of thought
no one here is dunking on aoc because
the fact is the left love to dunk on
unvaccinated people for getting coveted
and getting sick or getting or dying but
we're not doing that we know that
you can get it wherever you got that's
not our point but what is interesting is
why do they all go to florida well
because florida is america i mean look
we have all the freedoms down there so
my question though is how is this going
to turn out for because i think that her
original you know theory was i'll go
down to florida i think that she wanted
to be seen which is why she was being so
public and she was going to come back
and then spread this disinformation that
oh i went to florida and because they're
so you know unprotected i end up getting
covered now the the question though is
that does that backfire on her right
while she may say oh i went to florida
and i got covered what she also has to
say is i'm triple vaxxed and it still
didn't stop from me being able to get
this which means that i'm just as
protected unvaxed as you are vast so you
know again i think this is going to
backfire on her massively with her whole
scheme but it was certainly not about
her boyfriend's feet and all about
politics yes
and and i will say this i'm one of the
few conservatives who felt that his feet
were attractive
i know nobody wanted to say that at the
time but i looked at his toes and i said
that's that's an elegant man's foot
cat all right good glad you found some
happiness i did i did i have some
photographs i'd like to show you later
of his foot that i blew up to the size
of a full-length mirror that i like to
just crawl all over okay you know what i
expect cat
my supreme supreme my supreme
my supreme court my supreme court
justice
to be smarter than your average fifth
grader but she's as dumb as don lemon i
mean i mean come on that every where
could you okay where did you get that
stat well it's it's not anywhere no it's
not real yes but that's what i was
wondering is she dumb or did does she
really know that that's not true and she
just assumed people would believe that
it's real i think it's inspirational
like why can't i sit on the supreme
court yes because i knew that wasn't
true i could do a better job
uh but look and then again i agree with
you aoc she could have gotten covered
anywhere it's not necessarily a florida
thing uh i got two new york covid's
there's really just not that in new york
and there's not that much we can really
do this stuff doesn't work we're still
trying to do the same stuff over and
over again and so it doesn't surprise me
that they'd want to make up
things in order to try to keep it going
but why don't people like to live life
yeah and also i mean it did i think that
the it's effectively the idea that the
overcrowd is everywhere it killed the
idea of a vaccine mandate but i coined a
phrase a while ago uh you know what's
the definition of insanity
eating pickles in your underwear
i don't know where i went there
am i talking to you now
oh i love pickles
in my underwear i didn't know why what
you could be supreme court justice
because you have crazy opinions too i
think so no i actually do and i think
it's really scary the thought first of
all and i'll get on aoc in a second but
the fact that she was supposed to be
ruling on a decision whether it's
constitutional or not to impose these
national possible vaccination or testing
mandates and she doesn't even know the
facts behind covenants
just awful and i don't think she's dumb
i think that she actually believed what
she said i really honestly believe that
she so there you go so i'm i'm really
really faithful in i i'm sure that
they're going to be making some really
great decisions on mandating vaccines
one of the things that she actually
states
is that i don't understand the
distinction between federal and state
powers yeah crazy sit as the supreme
court justice member and tell america
that you don't understand the
distinction between state and federal
law that's why he's here
because i wouldn't have thought of that
joe last word to you well uh like judge
sotomayor i'm also a wise latina yes
you know latinx
i don't know where she got those numbers
from but um she did say the other 15
judges agreed with her
so
um
i think aoc got this not when she's in
florida i think she got it back at that
gala event
she just had extremely long coats
that needed a couple of months to fully
flower into the sniffles she currently
suffering from yes yes well i hope that
she feels better because like we're not
like them we're not gonna dunk on her
but we're just pointing out the
hypocrisies
that tend to permeate this uh
progressive wing of the party how does
that sound great thank you very much
you're gonna love it yeah really that
saved me excellent hey sean hannity here
hey click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else